You or someone you know may have been diagnosed with
type 1 diabetes
this video will help you understand what it is and
why is it important to keep it under control
Type 1 diabetes is a condition where your pancreas makes
little or no insulin
insulin is a chemical in your body to keep your blood sugar
at a normal level.
Carbohydrates are substances your body uses
to make energy.
after you eat food that contains carbohydrates
it eventually goes to your small intestine. in your small intestine
the food is broken down
into single sugar molecules called glucose.
the cells in your small intestine soak up the sugers
which pass  into your bloodstream
When the blood reaches your  pancreas
it detects the higher amount of sugar in your blood
normally it causes the pancreas to put insulin
into your bloodstream
The insulin reduces the amount of sugar in your blood to a healthy level
how does insulin do this
as the blood move through your body
The insulin and  sugar exit the bloodstream into your tissues
to reach your cells
most cells have structure on their surfaces
called insulin receptors when  insulin flows by
it attaches to the receptor
The insulin acts like a key in a lock
to open up the cell
so the sugars can get inside
now  your Cells can use the sugar to make the energy
it needs to work properly
and  your blood sugar level drops back to its normal range
if you have  type 1 diabetes
your pancreas lose its ability to make enough
or any insulin
this can result in high blood sugar level
and other complications
in type 1 diabetes
your immune system attacks your cells in pancreas
by mistake
as a result, your pancreas makes a little or no insulin
without insulin sugar can not get into your cells.
Without  sugars
your cells  don't have energy.
and since the sugar is locked out of your cells
it builds up to a higher level in your bloodstream
this is a condition called hyperglycemia
which can leads to serious complication.